نهر كومي ميمي يتدفق رقراقا بين ادغال
الامازون يعد هذا النهر شريان حيويا
لقبيله اورو ورم احدى مجموعات للسكان
الاصليين الذين سكنوا منطقه الامازون
البرازيليه قرونا عده ومع ذلك فان هذه
العلاقه
الممعنه في القدم بين الطبيعه والانسان في
منطقه الامازون تتعرض لخطر متزايد فالتوسع
مستمر في زراعه فول الصويا والمحاصيل
المعتمده بشده على المبيدات الحشريه فضلا
عن الرعي في اراضي السكان الاصليين بينما
يشجع لصوص الاراضي على ازاله الغابات بشكل
غير قانوني
يعني في الماضي لم يكن لدينا حدود اليس
كذلك لذلك اعتدنا الصيد بسلام دون ازعاج
قبل مجيء الانسان الابيض ولكن اليوم لدينا
هذا القلق الاكبر لان غاباتنا البكر محاطه
بهذه المزارع من يدري ما اذا كانت الغابه
ستختفي بشكل كامل في غضون عشره اعوام لهذا
السبب يجب علينا الحفاظ عليها
لحمايه انفسهم يطالب اهل واري بتفعيل
قانون محلي يعترف بالنهر كيانا حيا له
حقوق تراوح بين الحفاظ على تدفقه الطبيعي
وحمايه الغابه المحيطه به
ناتي ذلك في وقت يجتمع فيه ممثل ثمان
حكومات في امريكا الجنوبيه في مدينه
عاصمه ولايه بارا بمنطقه الامازون لمناقشه
سبل الحفاظ على غابات الامازون المطيره
والمساعده في درء تغير المناخ وحمايه
السكر الاصليين الرئيس البرازيلي لويس
ايناسيو لولادا سيلفا وفي مؤتمر صحفي قبل
بدايه القمه قال انه يسعى الى رسم سياسه
مشتركه لحمايه الغابات المطيره في القمه
لاول مره نريد اعداد وثيقه مشتركه لجميع
البلدان التي لديها غابات واجراء مناقشه
جاده للغايه مع الدول الغنيه للمساعده في
الحفاظ على غابه الامازون
اضحت غابات الامازون المطيره نقطه محوريه
للاهتمام بسبب التوازن الدقيق بين استغلال
الموارد والحفاظ على البيئه فانشطه
التعدين لها اثار بيئيه سلبيه على الغابات
بما في ذلك تدهور التربه وفي قيدان
الانواع كما تزايدت الحرائق وازاله
الغابات في البرازيل بشكل لافت خلال
السنوات الماضيه بين ان المد تغير مع قدوم
الرئيس لولاده سيلفا اذ تتلقى وكاله حمايه
البيئه مزيدا من الدعم المالي والسياسي من
الحكومه الجديده وهذا يحدث فرقه
بيانات الاقمار الصناعيه تظهر انخفاضا
بنحو 60% في ازاله الغابات مقارنه بالمده
نفسها من العام الماضي وكشفت الحكومه
البرازيليه في يوليو الماضي عن خططي
للوفاء بتعهداتها وقف ازاله الغابات بحلول
عام 2030 لكن يبدو ان ذلك سهل القول وصعب
التطبيق ثم تضغوط شديده من القطاعات
القويه في الاقتصاد المدعومه من المعارضه
المحافظه التي تسيطر على البرلمان
البرازيلي لتسريع الاستثمار والتنميه في
منطقه الامازون لكن التحديه هو ايجاد
الطريق للقيام بذلك دون تدميرها